true Thompson just had her first day of
school and her mama Khloe Kardashian is
feeling all kinds of emotions I am so
obsessed with her and I love it so much
to celebrate the four-year-old's big
milestone Coco got her daughter this
colorful balloon art and when the
company behind the first day of pre-K
display posted the photos on Instagram
the proud mom commented I'm still crying
that she's in school adding several
teary-faced emojis thank you for making
this day so special my favorite part
about being a mom I mean it's so corny
but it's just like no matter how tired
you are whatever you just it's complete
Bliss it's been a big year for true not
only did she start school she became a
big sister I cannot believe it Chloe and
true's Dad Tristan Thompson welcomed
their second child a son via surrogate
in July and we got a front row seat to
baby boys arrival on the season 2
premiere of The Kardashians
[Music]
all right how does it feel to be a mom
of two well it's about two hours in
so far it's going good yeah and you have
to check out this sweet moment of true
seeing her little brother for the first
time hi tutu
do you want to see someone yeah who do
you want to see
baby daddy
his name is not snowy
okay let's clear this up his name isn't
snowy baby's name has yet to be
announced but Coco did give us a hint it
is going to start with a t i I mean
that's really the only names I've been
looking at oh and her friends and family
didn't shy away from throwing in some
ideas 10 tiger Cory named the baby ten
tiger
tied King Triton
while Chloe's son's name Still Remains a
mystery one thing we do know is true's
loving the fam's new edition shortly
after the birth A source told ET she's
so thrilled to have a baby brother she
is loving every moment about being a big
sister and wants to be a mini Mommy to
the baby it's a beautiful thing and a
separate Source tells E.T she's obsessed
with her little brother and considers
this a dream come true for her
[Music]
foreign